france 3 partenaires de la semaine de la
presse à l'école nous avons passé une
journée avec les collégiens d'aillant
sur tholon dans l'yonne il participe à
un concours préparé la une de leur
journal de la recherche des informations
aux illustrations une rédaction en
pleine effervescence des journalistes
concentrés sur leurs sujets bienvenue au
collège la croix de l'orme d'aillant sur
tholon ou des élèves de quatrième sont
en train de travailler sur la une d'un
journal
on est avec mélodie et son équipe alors
mélodies sur quoi vous travaillez
aujourd'hui travail sur la lutte ou
qu'islam aux phobies et le racisme anti
musulman à partir d'un article
on va sur mines et les éléments
essentiels on va recréer un autre pour
expliquer les différences entre le
racisme anti musulman et ensuite qu'est
ce que ça va devenir en fait cette
sortie on va le taper sur l'ordinateur
et on va le mettre sur la une sur
laquelle on travaille alors la une d'un
journal c'est la toute première page du
journal qui va donner envie aux lecteurs
de l'acheter on est avec thierry roblin
thierry vous êtes professeur d'histoire
géographie
alors à quoi va ressembler la une de ce
journal aujourd'hui
et bien comme vous pouvez le constater
la une de notre journal qui s'intitule
un petit pas pour l'homme portera sur un
enfant tué sa soeur aux états unis en
résonance avec l'actualité aux états
unis et débat sur les armes à feu une
brève insolite trois touristes expulsé
au machu picchu pour avoir montré leurs
fesses et également une brève
évoquant la violence qui est faite aux
femmes et en particulier aux filles de
moins de 15 ans
comment ont été choisis ces sujets alors
en fin de compte ce sont les élèves qui
ont travaillé par îlots dont constitué
par petits groupes
on leur a distribué ce matin les
dépêches
et ils ont ensuite choisi plusieurs
articles
un article plus conséquent pour
fabriquer la maquette de ce que sera
cette une de journal
en espérant remporter le concours alors
vous l'aurez compris l'enjeu est de
taille puisque ces élèves participent à
un concours de unes nationale l'objectif
est donc de faire la une la plus belle
possible et pour les aider et bien il y
à sylvie benaïssa leur professeur de
français
sylvie on voit beaucoup d'ordinateurs
ici qu'est ce qui se passe alors ici on
a des élèves qui ont travaillé ce matin
donc sur les dépêches qui nous ont été
fournis et qui ont ensuite travaillé sur
des illustrations personnel des dépêches
qu'ils ont pu lire de l'autre côté on a
des élèves qui ont travaillé sur une
infographie ils ont réalisé la semaine
dernière un sondage ils ont pu
interroger leurs camarades de 4e sur
leurs habitudes dans le domaine de
l'information et donc ce matin il était
sur ce poste pour réaliser une
infographie pas intégré à la une c'est
quoi l'objectif de tout ce travail
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de faire en
sorte qu'ils se rendent comptent
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas se passer
l'information c'est important d'être un
citoyen à part entière et savoir d'où
vient la formation savoir à avoir un
regard critique sur l'information et la
nécessité de passe se cloisonner mais au
contraire de s'ouvrir chose qui se passe
autour
alors comme vous le voyez il ya pas mal
d'illustrations qui ont été réalisées ce
matin donc là pour la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme on voit deux beaux
dessins et il ya également un dessin sur
une illustration sur le machu picchu et
ça ce dessin cet homme qui la risée tome
qui est avec nous horton comment est-ce
que tu as trouvé l'inspiration pour
faire cette illustration
bah j'ai trouvé la dépêche drôle enfin
trouvé ça original donc c'était dans la
catégorie insolite
donc ça m'a plu de faire le dessin
nature j'ai trouvé ça marrant
qu'est ce que tu as voulu représenter
temple maya avec les trois touristes et
qui montrent leurs fesses
ça va correspondre à l'article oui parce
que la professeure la choisit donc je
pense que ça doit être assez
correspondant oui qu'est ce qui te plaît
dans ce travail c'est pas trop j'aime
bien ça original de faire un travail
toute la matinée ont fait jamais des
trucs comme ça du coup ça ça casse la
routine alors malheureusement pour des
raisons de confidentialité par rapport
aux concours la une ne peut pas être
dévoilés pour l'instant ce que l'on peut
vous dévoiler en revanche c'est ce
sondage réalisé par les élèves de 4e
auprès de leurs camarades
un sondage selon lequel 96 % des élèves
ne vérifierait pas l'information
un chiffre alarmant à l'heure où les
fêtes news se multiplient sur internet